the movie opens up in a maximum security
penitentiary in japan where only the
most notorious criminals are kept two
guards are inspecting the cells one by
one and after a while they come across
the isolation cell which apparently
houses the most dangerous criminal in
japan suzuki he is a middle-aged man who
has been held captive for many years
after the guards leave suzuki smiles and
takes out one of his teeth a while later
the guards returned to inspect the
perimeter but by this time suzuki is
already out one of the guards senses
someone's presence and shows his torch
around the place however suzuki
showcasing his parkour skills evades the
light without making any noise he then
clings onto the wall until the guards
resume their checking just then the
guards reach the isolation cell and
realize that suzuki has escaped they
immediately call for backup and in no
time the place is surrounded by army
generals meanwhile we see suzuki running
through the penitentiary's roof while an
alarm blares in the background as he
reaches a dead end it suddenly starts
raining and the movie goes into a
flashback twelve years ago a new batch
of prisoners is brought to a medium
security penitentiary among those
prisoners is suzuki who is serving a 10
year sentence he is a shy individual who
never utters a word and has a strange
upside down mount fuji tattoo on his
chest we also get to know that suzuki is
notorious for escaping prisons as he has
already achieved the feat thrice the
guards are well aware of this fact but
they are certain that suzuki won't be
escaping this time around in the next
scene suzuki is escorted to his cell
which is a small room with a ventilator
at the top he stares at the ventilator
as if he has something in his mind
outside a guard talks to the prison
warden mr konomura and assures him that
they will take care of suzuki however
when he peeks through the door he finds
that suzuki has already escaped in no
time the penitentiary organizes a large
manhunt to track down the runaway
criminal they make an elaborate point to
circle the entire town believing that
the criminal is a genius or maybe
they're just idiots but surprisingly
they find him within 20 minutes without
even breaking a sweat for some reason
suzuki was running straight through the
train tracks later he is brought back to
the same cell but this time his hands
are cuffed that ought to do it meanwhile
when a guard peeks through his door he
finds that suzuki has covered his head
with a blanket enraged the guard shouts
at suzuki to sleep with his head out
because he doesn't like playing hide and
seek but the latter doesn't listen as a
result he is badly beaten up the next
morning we see the warden going through
records of suzuki's previous
incarcerations after a bit of research
he finds a strange coincidence every
time suzuki escaped from a prison he was
caught at the nearby train tracks almost
immediately at night the warden along
with a guard are on a routine checkup of
the place when they enter suzuki's cell
they are taken aback to find that he has
unlocked his handcuffs the hot-tempered
guard demands to know how suzuki pulled
off such a trick but as usual he remains
silent because of this he is once again
punished one day suzuki is seen playing
with a small wire he has somehow
smuggled it inside a cell and it is the
same tool that is helping him unlock his
handcuffs to those of you who are
thinking where he hides it well you know
the answer in the next scene the warden
leaves the prison to spend time with his
family for a week in his absence the
guards become complacent and this gives
suzuki the perfect window to execute his
plan he takes out a roll of wire and
tries unlocking the door with it after a
while a guard finally arrives to inspect
the place when he peeks through the door
he notices that suzuki has again slept
with his head covered however this time
he simply ignores it just then we are
shown that suzuki is watching the guard
from the ceiling he has already escaped
the cell and now he is waiting for the
right time to flee the building when the
guard leaves he climbs further up until
he reaches the top he then punches a
soft spot in the roof makes a hole and
gets the hell out of the place when the
guards catch wind of this they
immediately raise the alarm the warden
also finds out about the escape and
decides to return to the prison the next
morning as the officials are planning
the manhunt the warden arrives he
suggests to the group that they cancel
all of their plans and instead send a
single team to the nearby railway tracks
the officials are stunned as they
believe that suzuki is not stupid enough
to hide in the same location but when
the warden tells them he is sure they
agree surprisingly his prediction comes
true and the runaway criminal is again
captured near the tracks it seems as if
all his intelligence wanes off as soon
as he exits the prison or maybe he just
really likes choo choos the following
day the warden is rewarded for his quick
thinking and is promoted to a
high-ranking position at the ministry of
justice now he has to leave his duties
at the prison his new task is to visit
various penitentiaries around the
country and inspect the living
conditions of the prisoners on the other
hand suzuki again breaks from his cell
and is again apprehended near the train
tracks with each year passing by he gets
transferred to several penitentiaries
but none of them can hold him inside
because of this the media dubs him as
the breakout king and he becomes a
cultural icon i'd have called him david
train at one point he becomes so popular
that even the kids start idolizing him
following this the movie fast forwards
by 12 years where suzuki is being
transferred to the central penitentiary
this time he is under strict
surveillance as a bunch of guards have
been assigned just to look after him
even his cell is a nightmare it is
entirely made of concrete and has
several locks on the door here we get to
know that the cell is the same isolation
cell that we saw at the start of the
movie as soon as the guards leave suzuki
scans the entire cell and tries to find
anything that can help him escape one
day a guard arrives with food and places
it inside suzuki's cell as he prepares
to leave suzuki suddenly handcuffs him
and tries to hurt him as a result the
guard blows his whistle and calls for
backup in no time several men arrive and
beat suzuki to a pulp after he regains
consciousness he peeks through the small
opening in the door and tracks the
guard's movements as he is doing so
blood drips from his face and soaks the
iron bars the next morning the guards
add a few extra screws in suzuki's
handcuffs hoping that he cannot open it
this time before leaving they dish out
another brutal punishment on him in this
way suzuki starts passing his days he
deliberately attacks the guards gets
beaten up and soaks the iron bars of his
door with his own blood one day the
guards beat him up so badly that one of
his teeth falls out surprisingly suzuki
picks it up and starts smiling as if he
had planned it all along in the next
scene suzuki is seen drawing something
on the wall with his tooth when a guard
arrives he immediately places the tooth
in its original position inside his
mouth a few weeks later suzuki attacks
yet another guard this time he crosses
all boundaries and is given the ultimate
punishment they bring out a long chain
tie him up with it and make him stand in
a difficult posture days pass by but he
is still in the same condition one day
in a shocking turn of events suzuki
starts singing it is finally revealed
that he can speak the movie then fast
forwards by a year and poor suzuki is
still going through the punishment he
has started looking like a castaway and
maggots are seen running through his
hands where he has been cuffed
fortunately that evening the guards
enter his cell and eventually take the
chains off as a result he finally gets
to rest after an entire year meanwhile
ex-warden mr konomura arrives at the
penitentiary to inspect the facilities
there when he approaches the isolation
cell he notices a sick and fragile
suzuki however he simply ignores him and
walks away next we are taken to the same
night that we saw at the start of the
movie when it starts thundering outside
suzuki sets his plan into motion it
appears as if he has been waiting for
this day for over a year he takes out
his tooth and starts opening the screws
of his cuffs here we get to know that
suzuki was not drawing on the walls but
in fact he was just sharpening his tooth
so that it could fit the screws after
setting himself free from the cuffs he
approaches the door and starts shaking
its metal bars surprisingly due to the
constant dripping of blood the metal
bars have become rusty and they easily
come off with this he escapes his cell
and eventually the entire place in the
following scene we are taken to the past
on the day suzuki was born his mother
dies due to delivery complications while
his father is rotting inside jail due to
this he is raised by his extended family
one day as suzuki is practicing his
parkour skills in the woods he is
suddenly approached by his runaway
father the two bond for a while and
suzuki notices the same tattoo on his
father's chest unfortunately their
meeting is cut short when some officers
arrive and begin chasing the dad seeing
this suzuki thinks he's probably not
coming back with milk and vows to meet
his father someday back to the present
suzuki is again running through the
tracks when he is stopped by mr konomura
the ex-warden asks him to stop and
surprisingly he obliges after a while a
group of guards arrive at the scene and
take him away seeing that even the most
fortified of penitentiaries could not
hold suzuki the head of the criminal
department orders mr konomura to escort
suzuki to the deadliest prison on earth
the prison isle the prison isle is like
no other penitentiaries it is located in
the middle of the ocean with extremely
dangerous currents on all sides and more
importantly no damn trains nearby
furthermore the nearby waters also
contain sharks hence making escape
impossible the insides of the
penitentiary are equally terrifying
hundreds of guards are sanctioned around
the place and if a prisoner tries to
escape they are shot on site the
prisoners are also given poisoned food
which slowly makes them go insane the
hell's the point of that when suzuki
arrives at the place he is immediately
locked inside a cell the cell is just a
bunch of rods put together which
constricts suzuki around his whole body
as a result he is not allowed to move an
inch let alone escape elsewhere mr
konomura enters the prison library and
starts searching for information about
suzuki after a bit of searching he
eventually gets some old files and goes
through them back inside the prison
suzuki is meditating inside his cell
although escaping from the place seems
impossible he seems to have an idea in
mind after a while he ends his
meditation and opens his eyes he then
dislocates both of his shoulders and
slowly gets out of the tiny confinement
a prisoner notices him in the act but
since he is too intoxicated he doesn't
say a damn word meanwhile as mr konomura
is still engrossed in his research the
alarm in the island goes off however
instead of being worried the prison
warden becomes happy as there is
virtually no way to escape the island he
is also delighted that his guards
finally have an opportunity to kill a
prisoner mr konomura tries to tell him
that suzuki is a genius but the warden
ignores him and tells them that they
will begin the search operation the next
morning in the morning several guards
are dispatched all across the island and
each one of them is carrying a rifle as
the warden is briefing the rest of his
men mr kanamura suddenly arrives and
informs them that suzuki is in fact
looking for his dad who is also
incarcerated on the island this
surprises everyone and here the truth is
finally revealed it turns out that
everything was suzuki's plan all along
he deliberately got himself into prison
and escaped each time so that he could
finally reach prison isle his main
mission is to find his dad and escape
with him elsewhere suzuki finally meets
his dad and the duo has an emotional
reunion unfortunately mr konomura the
warden and a horde of other men are also
arriving at the same location
surprisingly when they reach there
suzuki and the old man are already gone
in the final scene of the movie suzuki
takes his dad to the edge of the island
where he has a paraglider ready the two
board the glider and fly away from the
place meanwhile mr konomura tries
interrogating an old man who lived in
the same room as suzuki's dad just then
he notices the same tattoo on this man's
chest and is taken aback the movie ends
as mr kanamera narrates that after all
these years of planning suzuki has
escaped with the wrong man subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching